اذا نفتح ملف جديد بعيدا عن الحرب
الاوكرانيه
ويتعلق بالتوتر القائم بين الصين وتايوان
اذا قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان احدى
وسبعين طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه الصينيه
بما في ذلك طائرات مقاتله و طائرات بدون
طيار دخلت منطقه تحديدا الدفاع الجوي
التايوانيه وذلك خلال الساعات الماضيه
واكدت وزاره الدفاع التايونيه ان 43 طائره
صينيه عبره
غير رسميه بين الجانبين
من جانبها اكدت رئيسه تايوان
ضروره تعزيز قدوراتها الدفاعيه لمواجهه
التوسع المستمر للاستبداد بحسب وصفها
الى اهميه مواكبه العصر والتقدم
التكنولوجي العسكري لبناء قوه دفاعا وطني
المستمر للاستبداد على النظام الدولي
والسلامه والاستقرار ومع التغييرات في شكل
الحرب وتقدم تكنولوجيا الدفاع الوطني
القياده الشرقيه في الجيش الصيني نشرت
فيديو لدوريات الاستعداد القتاليه
والتدريبات على الضربات الجويه المشتركه
في البحر والجوع حول تايوان وذلك في
الخامس والعشرين من ديسمبر اي بالامس
وقالت القياده ان القوه المدنيه ستتخذ
جميع التدابير اللازمه للدفاع بحزم عن
السياده الوطنيه وسلامه الاراضي
ومعنى من بيجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء
الجوء اي اي اذن شيماء مجموعه من التطورات
لكن الطائرات همم الصينيه المسيره تبدو هي
الابرص حاليا هل تحدثت همم بيجين عن اهداف
هذه الطائرات وهمم ما الذي كانت تفعله في
اجواء تايوان
نعم حسن كل هذه التطورات الاخيره وتصاعد
التوتر عبر مضيق تايوان ياتي بعد يومين من
اقرار الاداره الامريكيه مساعده ماريا
ضخمه تصل الى مئات
المليارات من الدولارات الامريكيه لتايوان
هذه الخطوه الامريكيه اثارت حفيظه بجينو
ورد الصين كان قويا من خلال بيان للخارجيه
الصينيه عقبه هذه المساعدات قالت بان
تايوان هو خط احمر وتوعدت بان يكون ردها
حازما تجاه الخطوه الامريكيه اذا يمكن
القول الحسن بان ردود الفعل الصينيه لم
تاتي السياسيه فقط بالايضا على الصعيد
العسكري من خلال التحركات العسكريه او
النشاط العسكري الذي تم ليس فقط جوا بل
ايضا بحرا تم رصد ما لا يقل عن اربع سفن
حربيه عبرت خطا الوسط في مضيق تايوان بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الرسميه التايوانيه كل هذه
التحركات الصينيه كانت قد اعلنت عنها
بالفعل بالامس من خلال بيانا للجيش الصيني
على موقع الرسمي تحدث ليله امس عن القيام
بدوريات والتدريبات عسكريه بحريه وجويه هي
تدريبات هجوميه وقتاليه عبر مضيق تايوان
واكدت خلال في بيانها بان هذه التدريبات
والنشاط العسكري ياتي ردا على الاستفزازات
الامريكيه والتايوانيه على حد سوائدا من
الواضح ان الرجيم لا تخفي ان تحركاتها
العسكريه في المنطقه وتنامي هذه التحركات
تاثيرات على الخطوه الامريكيه وايضا على
موقف تايبي الرسمي الذي اتى عقب الخطوه
الامريكيه بالقول بانها ترحب بالمساعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه اذن هنا توجه موقفها
الرسمي وتوجه تحركاتها على عسكريه
كريستاله واضحه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايضا الى تايوان الجار
التايوانيه التي تراها بيجين من خلال
تصريحات الخارجيه الصينيه خلال المناسبات
السابقه بانها جزء لا يتجزء من اراضيها
وكانت قد ارسلت رساله وا حقيله الدول
الغربيه وعلى راس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالقول بان تايوانيه خط احمر
اصيل لا تخفي موقفها الرسمي الحازم تجاه
ملف تايوان خاصه في رسائلها الموجهه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان هنالك
ايضا رساله رسميه تمدد فيها الصين بيئه
صفقات بيع الاسلحه الضخمه الامريكيه
لتايبي وذلك من خلالي همم رساله همم تنبيه
او تحذير او صالها السفير الصيني لدى
واشنطن خلال مناسباتنا السابقه كانت همم
تحديدا عقبه زياره رسميه لرئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي فلوسي في اغسطس
الماضي الى تايبي والتي اثارت غضب الصين
كانت ترى في هذه الزياره محاوله تنذي وضع
همم اولى الاسس العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
واشنطن بالتالي هذا يعتبر بالنسبه للصين
اعتراف رسميا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
باستقلاليه تايوان عن البر الرئيسي للصين
وان كان الى حد الان حسن لا توجد علاقات
رسميه دبلوماسيه بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتايون لكن الصين تستشرف هذه
العلاقات وتحذر من حدوثها باعتبار تايوان
جزءا من الاراضي الصينيه ولا يمكن ان تكون
هنالك علاقات دبلوماسيه رسميه الا مع
الحكومه المركزيه في بيجين اذا الصين
موقفها لم يكن سياسيا فقط بل ايضا ردود
الفعل العسكريه تشمل همم تدريبات جويه
وبحريه عبر مضيق تايوان
هناك شكرا لك شيماء همم كنتي معنا من بيجي